le portrait du prince héritier des
émirats arabes unis mohamed ben zayed
piétiner puis brûlé l'accord entre les
émirats arabes unis et israël suscite un
sentiment de trahison dans les rues de
jérusalem est les palestiniens de la
bande de gaza ont eux aussi protesté ce
vendredi contre l'accord annoncé entre
les émirats arabes unis et israël il
rejette ce nouveau plan de normalisation
des relations entre l'état hébreu et un
pays arabe
cet accord est un crime contre la cause
palestinienne et c'est pour nous le
message que les émirats met fin au
conflit avec israël
cet accord donne à israël il chances
d'un excès plus de terres palestiniennes
de construire plus de colonies et le
tuer plus de palestiniens
il laisse également à israël les mains
libres à jérusalem est pour la basilique
du saint sépulcre les émirats s'il ne se
rétracte pas doivent être immédiatement
isolé par le reste du monde arabe qui
doit dénoncer leurs actes criminels et
prendre fait et cause pour le peuple
palestinien dans l'esprit du projet de
libération et de la position
palestinienne
avec cet accord israël s'engage à
suspendre son projet d'annexion de
territoire palestinien selon les émirati
mais benyamin nétanyahou a tout de suite
déclaré qu'il n'y avait en rien renoncé
le premier ministre israélien a précisé
que le plan d'annexion de la vallée du
jourdain et seulement reportée sur la
scène internationale certains dirigeants
à travers le mans nourrissent néanmoins
l'espoir d'une reprise des pourparlers
de paix au moyen-orient des news
screaming flammes les nouvelles en
provenance des émirats arabes unis et
d'israël sont les bienvenus nous nous
félicitons de cette nouvelle bien sûr la
normalisation sera au bénéfice des deux
elle est importante pour les deux et la
stabilité régionale les deux pays sont
nos partenaires et l'union européenne
est très attaché à trouver une solution
bi partite israël suspendrait
l'application de sa souveraineté sur
certaines zones de la cisjordanie
occupée
nous considérons que cela représente un
élément important car ces projets
constituent un obstacle majeur à la
reprise des contacts directs entre les
palestiniens et les israéliens
je salue la décision courageuse des
émirats arabes unis
et souhaite qu'elle contribue à
l'établissement d'une paix juste et
durable entre israéliens et palestiniens
je les dis au président trump au premier
ministre netanyahu et au prince héritier
mohammed bin zayed
mais cet accord a également suscité de
vives réactions de la turquie et de
l'iran qu'ils accusent le pays du golfe
d'adopter une attitude trop complaisante
vis-à-vis d'israël et d'agir au nom de
leurs seuls intérêts les américains ne
comprennent pas la réalité de la
situation des palestiniens en palestine
occupée
ils croient qu'à travers cette mise en
scène artificielle qu'ils ont
malheureusement joué hier ils peuvent
déterminer le sort de la palestine
les émirats arabes unis s'efforcent de
présenter cela comme une sorte de
sacrifice pour la palestine alors qu'ils
trahissent la cause palestinienne pour
servir leurs petits intérêts
les émirats arabes unis et israël
doivent signer d'ici trois semaines à
washington le protocole de normalisation
conclu entre eux cet événement pourrait
modifier profondément les équilibres
géopolitiques dans la région et ouvrir
la porte à des accords de paix entre
l'état hébreu et d'autres pays arabes